Hi!
This morning, I caught Ms. Coffee Bean watching…
the PDF of this paper entitled “Using AntiPatterns
to avoid MLOps Mistakes”.
Ms. Coffee Bean, what were you thinking?
I guess you read it because you have little
to no idea about machine learning in the real
world.
Haha, no wonder since you are in academia
where all the work you do
ends in a paper.
But you know, there is life to machine learning
methods even after they have been presented
in a paper;
life you would like to know more about.
Okay, Ms. Coffee Bean, since I do not know
what else to do with you, what about this:
I found the data leakage antipattern the most
interesting one, but the writeup was quite
dense (since the paper is made for experts).
Let’s make it accessible to anyone by explaining
this together!
Alright, Ms. Coffee Bean!
This paper is sharing lessons about MLOps,
which is all about putting machine learning
models into production,
but also about maintaining the whole operation.
However, the lessons of this paper are not
about what to do, and good strategies and
patterns, but more about what not to do, so
about the antipatterns (or antipatterns).
Clearly, the authors summarize their experience
here, which means that the lessons are more
tailored for the financial sector.
But don’t worry though, they’re applicability
is much wider than this.
The paper guides us through antipatterns ranging
from technical errors, to cases of missing
knowledge about the context in which machine
learning is deployed.
Data leakage is one of 9 antipatterns in this
paper… yeah each with catchy names.
But data leakage is the most interesting one
to me because these days, I have been interested
in the bigger question of model generalization.
Since the train-dev-test split is one very
weak test for model generalization,
data leakage is the one responsible for not
letting us perform even this simple baseline
for generalization.
Data leakage is a violation of one of the
first axioms that we are taught in every machine
learning course:
Do not let samples from the test set leak
into your training set and vice-versa, otherwise
you will overestimate your performance since
your model is already familiar with the data
you are testing on.
So how can this be an antipattern if everybody
knows about it?
And, it is quite easy to implement, right?
Well, no, it is not that easy to ensure total
separation between train and test data.
The authors report four ways of accidentally
enabling data leakage.
Each one is sneakier than the other.
Okay, great.
We are ready to see the data leakage antipatterns.
Shoot!
The Peek-a-Boo Antipattern is specific to
time-series data.
It is described in this little cryptic paragraph.
Now here is what Ms. Coffee Bean understood
from it:
Let’s suppose we have a time series, and
for splitting the data between train and test
set, we could say we take all the data up
to a certain time point t to be training data
and all the data after timepoint t to be test
data.
The splitting pattern could be also more complicated,
but the principle of the peek-a-boo antipattern
works the same.
The problem arises when time-series datasets
have at least two dates: the date of the actual
time stamp of the data point, but also for
example the date when the data becomes available
like in job salary data, which becomes available
in March but speaks about February, so about
the last month.
This time lag and the exact timing of things
might be unknown to the machine learning engineer
and messing around timestamps can really mess
up the train-test separation by accidentally
including data from the train set, from the
past,
into the test set, from the future.
Combine this with a feature that is highly
predictive of another feature and we will
have completely overestimated
our abilities of predicting the future through
this lag.
So, what is the real lesson here apart from
train-test separation?
Know the data you are trying to model, know
what every tiny feature means!
The next data leakage antipattern called “temporal
leakage”
is also related to time-series data.
With an ideal test set, we would estimate
the model’s true performance when deployed
into the real world.
Ideally the test set would be independent
from the training set to estimate how well
the model performs in unexpected situations.
But this paper warns us that if we take a
time-series data and sample train and test
sets from it in a non-sequential manner, then
the two are not independent anymore because
we have technically seen the future during
training already.
So, we have turned this into an easier interpolation
problem what was previously an extrapolation
problem of predicting the future, which is
harder.
The next type of leakage is “oversampling”.
It talks specifically about oversampling techniques
that are usually applied if one class is very
underrepresented in the data; Strategies like
SMOTE – or similar methods – basically
interpolate between the few existing points
to create new points.
So in a sense, the data has been smeared out
to have a larger population in the feature
space.
But you see the problem: The new interpolated
points would be informed about all points,
from train and test alike.
Therefore, if we split only after the oversampling
strategy, we would have contaminated the test
set with train set information and also the
other way around, of course.
So from antipatterns 2 and 3 we can remember:
the order of data pre-processing steps and
splitting into train and test splits, matters!
The last mentioned antipattern responsible
for data leakage is called “metrics from
beyond”.
To Ms. Coffee Bean, this is very similar to
the oversampling strategy.
This talks about other operations, that if
performed before train-test splitting, could
smear out information from one set to the
other.
One example could be data normalization by
subtracting the mean and dividing by the variance
for example.
If we do this for train and test together,
the normalization operation informs the future
train set of the mean and variance of the
whole set, including the test set; and vice-versa,
of course.
Which data leakage antipattern is the one
that you hate the most?
And if you are honest: which one of these
traps have you fallen into at least once so
that you had learned the lesson forever?
What are other data leakage examples that
you would like to share with us?
If you are interested in what you have seen
so far, read the whole paper to find out about
all other anti... antipatterns.
Until Ms. Coffee Bean will see you again,
repeat after her: “always separate your
train and test data like your life depends
on it!”
Okay bye!